so missus you're welcome you're right oh
you did very good thank you
good fantastic yeah so we're gonna need
to listen either yo now through we've
got Tyneside and a few of the bits and
pieces as well yeah and since I met you
you've had a an idea that I think is
probably one of the hardest things I've
ever heard it's a sort of the sort of
story that you hear about in the news
but you never actually know anyone who's
going to go ahead and do it so I guess
in short what what's your next three
months gonna look like what you do I'm
gonna row wooden rowing boat from
Portugal to Venezuela which has actually
never been done before by anybody so no
it's been done by a team five guys
before but never done by someone on the
right so I'll be like the world's first
so you're rowing across the Atlantic
Ocean
yeah on your arm yeah from mainland
Europe from mainland South America which
is important because there's a race that
exists where people go from the Canary
Islands to the Caribbean so it takes in
sort of 80% of the Atlantic Ocean and
it's long story short it's 20 grands
later and there's more kudos attached to
go from mainland Europe to mainland
South America right there's about a
thousand miles longer I have been there
the race so that's the reason for
choosing that mm-hmm and then also the
fact that no one's ever done it before
so there's not many things left that no
one's ever done yeah there's no
especially an exploration and stuff in
adventures so it's one of those like
last things to grab and it just sort of
built that's it
you know as it evolved its sort of built
into what it is now mm-hmm the initial
intention was to just throw the Atlantic
and in design in any way possible so
again in any way possible yeah ever bit
to whatever videos and being kind of
naive to it I was just like well I want
to roll the Atlantic what's the most
common form of doing that and then
outsider and then looking into it human
back the ladders you sort of figure out
what's on offer and then through a bit
of sort of bucking against the rules and
so they're not wanting to conform I
ended up getting my own my own route so
basic is this company called Atlantic
campaigns you could run the task or
whiskey Atlantic challenge and it's the
sort of the standard bearer if you like
an ocean rowing and it's 20,000 pounds
to any of that race is that solo as well
oh yeah they they take on sale when
trees pears threes fours I think I might
have done five but I think fours
actually the highest they do and
basically I looked at what you get for
the 20 grand now I'm not putting it down
towards a fantastic organization it does
great things but for someone that
doesn't come from particular background
and then 20 grands like quite a bit of
cash just to find to enter a race
especially when you spend upwards of 70
grand to buy the boat in the kit and all
the stuff you need yeah so I basically
about seven years ago I set the scene so
about something a little yeah it's I was
living in London working private
security and basically got invited to a
dinner party and one of the girls at the
dinner party was a film director right
so I'd asked if she'd worked understand
recently and she'd just finished a film
on a guy called Charlie picture right he
drove the Atlantic on his own
independently so I watched that film and
sort of transfixed by it everyone else
it has been a part you didn't really
want to you know think about doing that
yeah it was I don't think there's anyone
that really think so doing that right
yeah yeah it's the sort of thing that
you hear other people talk about but
yeah I don't know it just look for me
that's exactly how it was so but it you
know like most things the curiosity got
the better of me and I sort of I email
Charlie to find out the ins and outs of
ocean rowing and how someone goes about
that planning that sort of thing and so
he sent me all the links to the Tallis
chorus and through that I figured out
it was gonna cost nor that sort of stuff
so I had set aside a bit of time to save
for it and then like I said in in
researching more about ocean rowing I
came across other people that done
independent rows right and there's a
whole community right yeah it's huge
once you give scratch the look like the
layers away absolutely over the last
year just seeing stuff that you like in
sea and there's you know ice rowing all
over the place yeah and it's almost like
it's like when people get into training
like we've never been exposed to like
gym life before and as soon as you think
up all the lingo and all that sort of
stuff so it's a definitely like a
subculture that people pick up on a
notion Romans that way as well but more
people have climbed Everest than of
wrote the Atlantic and then again if you
look at the Pacific or the Indian Ocean
the numbers are even smaller again
that's a thousand at the moment I think
the figure stands at about 500 yeah but
the talisca race it's grown in
popularity so this year the race is
actually happen as we speak is 75 people
in the race it is again exponential yeah
so maybe 50 people all complete it and
has already beaten some dropouts and
stuff alone yeah a couple of rescues and
that's not an arrow and that's quite
humbling to see from my position like
I'm setting off in three weeks people
given up but as well as that there's a
guy called Damien brand who's a former
rugby player and he's basically setting
an example of how to tackle an ocean
road like he's got the former yeah and
if he thinks like kind of the way I like
to think about things so if you take an
event or something that happens to you
in your life if you can react to it one
of two ways but that doesn't change the
fact that that event has occurred so you
can lose your temper or you can laugh it
off but the event is still there to deal
with so it doesn't really matter how you
react to something you're there and
you've got to get on with it but there's
a few you know in times gone by there
are people that have sorted for whatever
reason withdrawn from the race and I'm
I'm starting to to change my like
- reaction to that like mayor Shaw
reaction on hearing that sort of news
would be there I they can hack in it
wasn't for them and all the sort of
stuff but a few of them have raised
safety concerns that they perhaps didn't
think about when the lead up to throat
there's so much that goes into the
planning that I totally understand that
from their position they might have got
to a point where they hadn't really
considered what they were getting
themselves into yeah I know that sounds
daft because it's rowing an ocean but I
think it's easy to get caught up in the
hype and sort of find yourself in a
position if they don't really want to
work prepared yeah so tell us about your
background what's what's your what's
your parent so basically I grew up and I
really like to sort of transient
lifestyle so my father was in the Armed
Forces
I was born in Germany and then ended up
living all over the place and then when
I was 18 I joined the Marines on a dare
yeah so basically was a TV program on
while we're at school and everyone was
talking about this TV program sort of
would they fancy doing it and all that
sort of stuff
and again another situation where I
think I was the only person that wanted
to yeah and then later that day I was
stooping the queue for some food at
school and I overheard two lads talking
about the fact that I want particular to
go write one whole holt's I was like 17
or 18 right it's like a levels yeah and
I even heard someone saying they didn't
think I could do it and not being sort
of that academically minded and not
knowing what I wanted to do if I got the
university you know that sort of stuff I
just decided to run it by a man or old
man first yeah saying when they drop out
of school and doing the Marines what do
you think and he was like yeah go for it
I guess with his background that would
have been yeah so did that left the
Marines got into private security did
that for a few years and you know just I
think you can tell from that background
I've always been a fan of like
challenges and figuring out who I am and
how they acted like stressful
environments and sort of extreme
situations and I just feel like it's
been a few years since that's happened
so the roofs are coming in a good
mm-hmm so this has been a concept in
your mind for about seven years
yeah I think six or seven years see
there 2010 or 11 I watch that that video
did a party yeah since then it's just
sort of evolved but obviously with the
amount of money involved and obviously
with the age I was like bang how it
isn't you know get a car and a nice ass
at 70 grand is like hard to come by when
you do it all that 70 thousand pounds is
because I probably spent so far about
seventy thousand I say so far because
it's still more stuff to get for sure
yeah so it's just it's little things
like there's probably a katniss with two
or three hundred items on that you need
to do the road Wow
and most of the items cost a couple
hundred quid so you can you know gather
from that how much stuff and then in
amongst that is a bowl in amongst that
area yeah that's all is it but either or
like it's a rowing boat or a vessel
because they're the things I think
because of the stuff attached to it it
gets called the vessel because I have
like a radio and a GPS and I got me it's
basically a wooden rowboat with it
account smoking yeah so it's pretty good
so you've got you've gone through the
Marines you've gone through your private
secure you've come out the other side
now yeah I've seen you just over the
last year I've seen you run coast to
coast of Hadrian's Wall yeah that was
them so that that wasn't really a big
thing for us and his absence I saw my
own a big-headed and it's not meant to
sound that way it was the equivalent of
somewhere in the region of three
marathons back to back and what exactly
what well it's actually 328 mile runs
back to back so I'll set the scene again
Josh rose and I did run in November just
off the cuff to see how like fit we
thought we were and it was a trail
runner Wooler which was 28 miles and
then we literally finished it in ten
minutes our foods were talking about
people that do all the marathons and
stuff like that and I just 101
I think ultras anything over a marathon
to be honest yeah alright so if people
are doing 50k in call it an ultra okay
well I'll do 100 K in court or whatever
yeah Josh and I were basically saying do
you reckon you could do that
back-to-back and I was like I don't know
and then just off sort of googling and
flying around Facebook and stuff I found
two guys that had ran Hadrian's Wall and
it was 84 miles and it just jumped into
their head that that's pretty much
they're back again and there again and
the wrong we just did yeah she was the
biggest distance either over self-edit
that I've ever done I think up to that
point and only ten minutes after you
were already looking for me yeah so I
just jokingly said to him what do you
reckon about doing this and he was like
yeah that sounds pretty good
and then though I've always been a fan
of if you tell people about it then it's
happening yeah so I think we posted up
an Instagram that day and then to sort
of train towards it as I external
ability coming in a little bit yeah and
it's just sort of like I think it's good
to test yourself now and again of stuff
that you don't know you might be able to
do otherwise it isn't a challenge to
many people these days do you like a
marathon which no offense to anyone
that's proud of what they've done but
it's not hard to run 26 miles no matter
what your background or even if the
training are supposedly training for a
marathon I've seen some of the training
protocols and people are working up
towards 20 miles like 10 and 20 miles
beforehand but unless something goes
wrong the race is all right you've
already run it which is actually the
edges to my heart of the training right
yeah the point of the training is that
you should be able to complete the run
comfortably yeah but I think there's a
difference in trying to complete an
event which you've prepared for and
trying to test yourself in a way that
you can only prepare up to as well as
you can do for yeah that makes sense
yes and I think also if you apply a
timeframe to the market and then it
becomes a challenge yeah but for most
people they just want to do it and it's
more possible than people think it is
yeah
and I think there's loads of stuff in
life that's like that it's way more
possible than you think you just know
you haven't tried it before and the run
the hecklers were all run was definitely
that like in February we failed it well
I failed it because I got a shins
what do you call it a stress fracture a
machine right so that stopped us at
about the 65 mile point
still which is a long way it's not just
exactly double ya marathons and so that
was that but then because of kind of
kind of people Josh and I are we were
like wolf we've got to go back and
finish it I think that day the Instagram
bell see you put apply instead they
asked I think yeah yeah fun announcing
they hadn't happened yeah this is a
pretty much it was the announcement like
what yeah actually so to speak and the
date was good because it was the rerun
was in August just gone and it basically
for me was more of a test of like where
I was physically and mentally because it
it was a tough test in that like you had
to apply a better mental forward to get
through it because it's a long way to
run most people unhappy drive in that
distance but to run it we self at like
fallen them all and they finished it
10:00 at night and let's like coast to
coast of the country so it was quite a
deal and but also for me it was good
because on the roam I'm probably going
to be working out for up to 18 hours a
day and the run took around about the
same time right so the thought of
getting up the next day and doing that
all over again it was more preparation
and because I could turn around go world
it's possible but it's gonna be bloody
hard yeah and to string a hundred days
like that together it's really gonna be
the test so go back to the role you've
you've got your prep you've started to
get towards it something what's the next
step in terms of you've started to think
about the idea where do you go from
there you need to find the route you
need to find someone with specialist
information yeah exactly that is sort of
it's like most ideas that you know you
don't think you're gonna be able to
achieve just as soon as you start on the
road it just starts to evolve and I've
never really been someone that like
plans everything to an absolute tea and
then goes and executes it
I can sort of I trained myself up to a
point where I think I've got all the
skills I need to you know be able to
take on the challenge which involves the
whole planning phase as well yeah and
then I'll just react to the situations
as they as they come
yeah and as I'm going down that road so
basically like I said I emailed the guy
Charlie picture found out about costs
and you know required courses and like
the navigation that you need to like
pick up and a lots of stuff
and then just let me start going about
doing it but the real sort of the
emphasis was like injected into the
projects back in 2016 right because a
team of five guys had completed that
route that was on about three of them
were friends of mine from the Marines
right no way yeah so I called one of
them up and just said like what's what's
the score with this how do you go about
planning in except we just picked the
route and did it
so I basically the same sketch as the
run I told everyone I was doing it and
it kind of like forces you to make him
happen man for sure and also thicken of
date was important because it's
something to work toward and it's
something that like you're then
accountable for because people know
you're like it's January to Morton's
many be going often it's real absolutely
yeah markinson's a lot of the work
expands to fill the time that's given
for it and if you just at some point in
the future it would be five years ten
years before you know yeah I can't do
any more
exactly so know if that's I mean so
moving on to the actual row itself am i
right in thinking the red that 1.5
million or strokes around that yet I
mean it all depends on like the distance
it takes me but as a rule that's gonna
be about one and a half million Oryx yet
which just sounds like yeah the sort of
thing that would take its pace or do you
know I mean maybe of millions of
anything yeah millions of repetitions of
anything just sounds absolutely insane
yeah it's one of those weird things like
the closer you get to it and the more
people I know you've actually done the
road the more you realize that it's it's
everything you think it's gonna be it's
like incredibly monotonous and boring
testing and all this and you can have
music and sort of films to keep you
company and everything but at the end of
the day there's there's no getting away
from the fact that you've just got got
to get on the oars and pull and also
it's so much more different to anything
of them before we're on the run that
josh mike did yeah if we fail that it
was like the offer and ben was driving
the car next to us yeah so we could jump
in or we could like get our iPhones out
and call someone and they've come
but this is not like so what's the
support structure that you've got
there's no sport is completely
unsupported an absolute emergency I can
set off one of the many beacons I've got
on board and through the different
coastal agencies around the world
they'll sort of try and affect the
rescue the majority of the time use
rescues if from passing ships because
there's quite a few shipping lanes on my
route okay so there is the opportunity
to be rescued but that's if you're in an
emergency situation yeah it wouldn't be
looked upon very well if you sell few
beacon just because you're a bit tired
yeah yeah it's a weak feeling a bit
sorry for yourself and then failing that
there's a life raft grab bag of
emergency kit and then the current to
take me to the Caribbean bloody there's
something probably about 150 days maybe
okay that's definitely last resort yeah
it is a resort yes I guess if you've got
to have planning for every eventuality
like he said there's a lot of things
that could occur that you wouldn't know
yeah so when do you set off what time of
day and what date so you set like a
general date that you're aiming at which
for me is the 18th of January for no
other reason I've just plucked out of
the air
yep and then through the the weather
eaten guy my friend foxy we're just
going to look at the weather around that
we can see if it's a viable option
but generally January's a good time
right yeah it says of something going on
with currents yeah the telescope sets
off in December and I'm gonna start from
January basically for the same reason
that the trade winds come from Africa
Thord South America right and they're at
the strongest point at that time of the
year and also the hurricane season stops
in around November December time so if
you self obviously after the hurricane
season it's gonna be you know what quite
a few favors
so you're gonna get an assist at the
wind right yeah at least a little bit
yeah so this not to get too much into it
but there's two classes of boats there's
the pure class in the concept class the
concept class is basically like the
newest design which is an incredible
design and not to sound like I'm sort of
like hating on it it is a nominally
design but a kit and the people that
make them run ik definitely the best
boat builders out there but it's widely
known that they get huge wind assistance
because they're designed for that so the
entrance to the cabin is at the front of
the boat for the main cabin
whereas mine's at the back of the boat
yes so as the wind comes over the back
of the boat it doesn't hit anything your
mind
it just drifts off into the energy
whereas it's a flat surface yeah so it's
like a sail and because of that run I
could set these blistering fast paces
across the ocean any of the world
records that held are currently held by
right boats so this is there now two
classes yeah so Guinness were like well
that's not fair now we'd have to have
two classes so I looked at who holds the
record for my row that's an
old-fashioned pure class boat right so I
only thought it's fair if I'm going to
try and beat though like the record that
already stands yeah then I've got a good
has got the room you've been drinking
you're doing is never been done before
no and that would say irrelevant of
which side it was in which boat you were
in yeah I'm gonna be what specifically
for country to country I'll be the first
person yeah but for continent to
continent yeah someone's done it before
okay and the guys called scene half a
Norwegian that said it in 96 days right
and so if I beat 96 days I get the
records as well as being the first
person to go from Portugal to Venezuela
I'm the first British person and all
those sort of yeah all the sort of all
the sub years man
not very good I mean it's just it just
boggles the mind really so so I think
about this sort of stuff like on I can't
imagine what the experience is gonna be
like to go across so you I mean what's
the estimated time you hopefully send
off January 18th is yeah well in the
winning a morning thing is it the sort
of thing where you going to be able to
have only one to see you offer than a
support crew like yeah
so foxy the weather written guy he's
going to come out to Portugal with me
and then my friend Pierre is gonna help
me drive the boat down and then those
two basically I want as little time as
possible in the marina and Portugal
right why's that just like there's a
mental thing I think it's way better for
like say your buyers code for on at home
yeah
drive down put the boat jumping journey
else begins as yourself in the car
exactly yeah do you K yeah and also you
know like I said because we're getting
the weather and all that sort of stuff
you don't want to miss your other window
so if I do leave al you want to get down
there sure a two days like delay might
end up being a four-week delay which I
can't really afford so for me I just
want to get the boat in the water
himself
plus it isn't like a challenge that I've
ended up doing that I don't want to do
like I've been this like a dream of mine
for six or seven years so I'm like
chomping at the bit to get out there and
test myself and all that sort of good
stuff yeah and I think like the solitude
something when you enjoy like the
adventure side of it you know putting
yourself at the mercy of something you
can't control isn't something people do
very much these days
absolutely and I think that's where the
test comes from is like I'm not in
control of my environment and I can only
react to it so it's much the same as
like normal operations and the Rings
like it's a good test with who you are
or what you're about especially in this
world where people are so bothered about
sort of money and status and celebrity
you know that's for stuff like that
stuff doesn't really impress me
I like the only idols I have of you know
they've got the work done and then they
get the plaudits for it rather than
telling people what they're gonna do and
expecting some sort of for sure I mean
you know a lot of people I think would
be primarily chasing the titles and the
they want to do it the quickest they
wanted to yeah the fastest the best yeah
and get the most renowned out of it so
maybe that bonus is the truth
is the test itself yeah and if it takes
me only 20 days I'm not really bothered
the the records like a nice to have for
the sponsors and stuff like that
something that they can sing about and
say that they were involved with but for
me I don't really care about that it's
nice to know that you know you've you've
earned something and you've achieved it
because you outwork the other guy in all
that sort of stuff yeah but for me that
the big test is can I deal with what's
thrown at me like the conditions will
probably be different to the other guys
as well and the distance is so vast that
you can't do the exact same group anyway
right so the parameters of like well he
did it in this time and he did it in
that time they're hard to sort of you
know there's no direct comparison yeah
you can't create like that level playing
field works like a football match where
there's two goals in 19 minutes and off
you go in Fisher and so yeah it's just
it's a weird one because the records
mean a lot in the build up you know
getting funding and sponsorship and all
that but when it comes down to it I
getting from A to B safely's number one
I think that's what that's what grabs
attention isn't it yet that this is
potentially going to be a world record
hmm all right but as you say that for
you is below secondary yeah it will be
cool I mean like that the whole ego side
of things that'd be nice to be the first
person to have ever done anything
because you'll never lose that record
absolutely
whereas if you're obviously the fastest
you're the fastest up till someone beat
see yeah yeah and with the way that the
boats are going as well it'll come to a
point where the pure class folks no
longer no longer built yeah or they're
too old to be recycled so it's only a
concept class boats so then it would be
nice to be the last person to have done
something and all that sort of issue but
definitely I'm open to the thought of
after the first one that's done maybe
doing it again and a concept boho right
now but I've obviously got to do it
first and see if I like it let's get
over here so you're gonna sell off
January 18th
and then I'm writing saying that you
don't actually steer is that right it's
GPS that does the the majority of the
steering in terms of directions in the
air so you can have what's called an
auto helm and it basically attaches to
the rudder and it's a digital steering
device so you type in your bearings of
the GPS and then you can get it done
automatically or you can sync it
yourself as well you'll put the bearing
into the auto help and then it basically
steers for you so you just get on and
you just pop yeah and you just pull but
if that breaks you then go to foot
steering or hand steering which is as
bad as it sounds
yeah whilst whilst also trying to pull
your oars yeah and you're constantly
like readjusting it and sort of making
sure you're on the right bearings so if
you have you set your course no do you
know yeah so I went through it with them
foxi we sort of sat down the other week
spent about eight hours picking the
course so have you done it what are you
dinner recently yeah I mean that you've
had a lot of good ideas everyone knows
that I'm going from Portugal to
Venezuela so that's pretty obvious
yeah I just head west yeah but the
intricacies of sort of getting out of
Portugal and like breaking away from the
land so you can afford to get your head
down without like drifting into anything
yeah so the first sort of day will be
the first week it's going to be hell
because why is that you're just into
everything it's the first week where
you're like aware of what the routine is
going to be like is the first week where
your body's getting used to that
workload all you had like the blisters
and stuff in your hands are gonna form
and all that sort of thing like you can
train them to a certain extent and like
the nice comfy confines of a gym and my
view but when you actually get on it you
can't really train for an ocean road
unless you're on ocean yeah for sure
suppose that you've touched on it there
so I'm going to segue off yeah just take
the three training take us through what
the training is consisted of um I think
that's always a hard question to answer
because
you know chunker society that trains all
the time and they have goals outside of
these big projects so like I train most
days and have done since I was 16 or 17
but the rose specific stuff I knew I had
to get fat and you had to get strong and
I knew I had to have a pretty good
engine lucky have had a good engine for
a while and so that kind of took care of
itself here and that run was like
confirmation of that yeah and then I get
fat get fat to be really weird really
weird it's gone really well but it's
been really strange obviously most
people that train a train to go looking
good or be nice when you look looking
good when you're naked and all that sort
of stuff and I've had to do the opposite
of that
yeah I've had to eat for a purpose which
goes against everything that like I
people I stay with like stand for so
that's to be really weird but um it's
it's doing I'm getting better in it now
because I know that it's gonna like it's
getting better a big fat yeah but I'm
getting better at putting the food and
not being that bothered by it because I
know it's gonna like serve me well one
there the time comes but ya know it's
really weird how I have our strength so
this is probably I'm gonna guess that
this would be the heaviest you've ever
be yeah 112 kilos at the moment from 85
in August oh my god
so that's quite it quite a game very
sharp and it's not like you know
obviously you can judge for yourself but
a lot of people have said that I'm
carrying it pretty well like a regular
claimant so if I was to do it again but
I think that comes from the strength
training that I've been doing so I've
added bulk as well as fat definitely
with my top off and stuff I'd look
flabby and I've got curves where I don't
want them that's what was definitely but
working with Tim Briggs who does we
don't need nutrition we were like well
the first part the first part part of
getting fat is just eating more than you
need to get fat doc yeah it's been
emailed
so we just overloaded on carbs and like
ate a diet where my body got all the
nutrition it needed yeah like so a lot
of the stuff that Lauren cooks I believe
the same set yeah and then on top of
that there's been like pizzas and ice
cream and chocolate okay whatever you
want to do to get calories up and then
recently maybe three or four weeks ago
we switched to like a keto diet okay so
the idea is that my body now is going to
be better at burning fat round and the
transition happens now rather than on
the rope okay so I've already
experienced sort of like headaches and
you would you say you've dropped into
ketosis now that it's probably saying so
yeah another cuspid I'm feeling better
in on it now yeah and I did get sort of
quite a few headaches and was feeling
like dreary and a bit hungover in the
mornings and stuff and then also you
yeah I was just you know it's been nicer
on the based diet rather than like that
car be sugary stuff because I think that
you're awful really yeah and now I'm
coming out with the transition as well
it feels I don't feel a lot more
energetic and so healthier um because I
think that's I mean for a lot a lot of
people who have had to suffer the pain
of fat and protein diet that's for most
people really uncomfortable mm-hmm they
don't like the fact that they don't have
that starch yeah and if bulky satiated
feeling that you get that comes along
with having carbs hmm so that's the
that's the diet side so yeah I said of
training what have you been doing to
prepare a lot of time on a concept to
I'm gonna guess yes there is that I mean
it doesn't really crossover that much to
ocean rowing so really yeah and the two
hours set on a concept to I can pull the
fairy commas which is a good pace but
then when I first got my boat I rode it
from the time bridge to the Royal Keys
which is eight miles and it took me two
hours oh wow so the weight of the boat
how slow she goes in the water and all
that sort of stuff like it makes it so
much different to the concept to you but
you're not going to do any damage beyond
the concept to so it's a nearest you can
get to it without getting on the boat so
a lot of to our sets one-hour sets rode
through the night one time did like 70 K
in one saying that was it the gym across
a time side yeah and then most
the time it's just sort of general
prepared Fitness with Lauren so training
most days together in mornings we just
didn't like CrossFit Li silver stuff so
a lot of functional movements and so
that I thought I was obviously thought
there'd be a lot more row specifics
about genuinely thought he would just be
yeah just spent the last six months our
concept to and then some accessories
work but it would appear that yeah they
cross over from doing more functional
stuff actually appears to be more
beneficial in yeah I think so I'm
looking at like that talus the race like
you like going back to you people take
that pretty seriously and people train
for it or have training for it with this
like the thing you've just said they're
like sat on the concept to you yeah most
is a trying yeah and then doing a little
bit of accessory stuff and it hasn't
really worked as well really as people
that have come in recently with like a
endurance sports background who have
done more so the functional training and
then they've done a bit of little bit so
well-rounded azar Feliz yeah so I think
it's more like training for the Marines
world she like you've sort of ready for
anything like they were good sprint no
you strong gym nasty and all lots of
stuff in there and I think you know
that's definitely worked well I've been
into robust as you can possibly be
I suppose it must make the training as
well building up to something that is
going to be a bit monotonous the fact
that you can go in and one day do rock
climbs and one day do pull-ups or one
day do concept too and then yeah I mean
like it yeah well my thought is to save
the monotony for the after all the event
itself it sounds like it's gonna be a
little bit yeah yeah I'm a happier that
I could sit in a row before for like 14
hours or whatever I've done it before
yeah I'm happy I can workout for 18
hours having done it before and like I
said the Rose more mental than it is
physical like it's gonna be debilitating
and hard work and all that sort of stuff
but I think like the overriding rule or
mantra in my life is is always somewhat
worse off than yourself yeah and yes I
think whatever situation you're in is
not that bad
if you keep our minds I'm not sure
there's gonna be very many people on the
planet they're gonna be doing as many
hours
day Niyazi self during that period yeah
there's a crazy crazy thought he thinks
seven billion people on the planet and
you will be easily in the top not 0.1%
of people working out for three months
yeah it's nice well there's a famous
Brad Wiggins explains the Tour de France
by saying it's the only sport event on
the planet wait neither hair hair cut
halfway through like 93 also but it's
also apart from the working out side of
things like I have to be a carpenter an
electrician a water make it specialist
all these different things because if
anything breaks on the boat
there's no one to fix it but me you've
said to me that one of the first things
that you said about the race was you
need to be able to take apart and put
back together every single element yeah
it's upside down in the dark so wow it's
pretty stalkers to talk us through the
vessel of the boat talk us through what
is so she's 24 feet long there's a cabin
at the front and at the back that are
both enclosed in airtight right the one
at the back is the one I sleep in
it's about there's basically coffin
dimensions it's like six foot by two
foot built for you how many much else
means very much yeah and in in the cabin
I've got sort of food a memory foam
mattress and sleeping bag and then I've
got like the GPS the radio the thing
called a is which is like an indication
system that tells me and other ships who
each other are right and I should say
stay away from me your release yeah then
the forward cabin front of the boat is
where I'm gonna have it's mainly for
storage you can't really get in there
and it's just going to store things like
the parachute unclear and all that sort
of thing right and then the deck itself
has got to Rome positions and six oars
why that's it why two wrong positions
just sauce basically so Mike boat can be
rode by one person or two people right
and and there was not to you to like
condense the two positions into one just
as a sake if I miss early or over so
don't mean to but then we talked about
with a project manager that when they as
I get halfway through and I've eaten
half of the food
and obviously half of the the weight of
the boat was disappear is yeah it would
be nice to have the opportunity to
either owe more forward or more back at
the boat so I can affect the boats to
believe in the water
yeah because ballast it's like a big
thing with those boats so that's the
reason we kept the two positions and
also just to break up the monotony a
little bit yeah I know it sounds really
they're really like a foot apart from
each other but just a holiday in the
front and one thing in the back I
remember one of the first questions that
I asked you and I'm sure that some of
the listeners are thinking this as well
the guys the boats that have two or
three or four people in them you would
think would be able to get across
quicker mmm done a bulb that only has
one person in them you have more people
more horsepower yeah but you said that
that wasn't strictly the case no and
it's been proved in the last two talisca
races so it's all like power-to-weight
ratio so they can go faster but they're
carrying more weight and they're doing
it in two hours sort of sessions so if
we were doing it air for example like
I'd be Roman while you're asleep and
vice versa but the pace is pretty much
the same because our boat would it would
weigh what it would wait for two people
whereas my boats only gonna have 400
days worth of food instead of 200 days
yeah so only one person yeah I've got a
shift less weight so effectively I can
keep same sort of speeds yeah over a
24-hour period as we could do in two
hour you know similar segments yeah so
in the last two tasks oryx's last year
my friend Gavin Hanigan came third
overall as so liberal right the teams of
two and three and four Wow and there's a
guy Marc slats who's doing it this year
and he's third as a solo and a team you
know never a full of fours and threes
which is which just seems so coming Jeff
I suppose book yeah when you've got the
amount of food for that many more people
and all the rest of it yeah I mean
that's just and they're rowing probably
20 hours a day those two server guys
just mentioned 20 hours a day everyone
about 20 hours a day yeah so what's the
logic behind because obviously that's
going to cause I guess a little bit more
yeah he ain't playin our next day by me
mark at the moment they've been going
two weeks he doesn't seem to have slowed
down any yet obviously you can't keep
that up forever so yeah everyone sort of
stuff yeah so for me for example I I'm
just gonna road see how I feel and judge
everything off off that there's no point
in me making like a schedule now that
I'm gonna have to change when I get on
the road so I'm just gonna sort of Rover
an hour or two in see how it feel if I
feel like you should rest a little bit I
will get some food down me the water and
stuff and then I feel like I want to
carry on and give it a big stint I will
so in for the rowing aficionados out
there have you got an idea of sort of
cadence of stroke rate stuff like that
yeah so it's a very basic sort of
measure you'd be doing around 18 to 20
strokes a minute and to be honest with
you that's all that really counts for
the aficionados out there because the
boats like I said before if I do two
hours on a concept to you in two hours
on my boat the distance is like half two
basically so it was that was a big
eye-opener because obviously you spend
the whole time looking at your screen on
the concept to think and write if I pull
130 per 500 that's awesome yeah doing
really good yeah if it's to blah blah
and you're doing all this mass in my
head and then as soon as you get on the
boat that just all those other windows
so it's just efficiencies and guided by
your stroke rate and 18 to 20
sustainable for 100 days and that feels
about right to you as well yeah it feels
nice and also because it's an ocean and
not like a river boat a lot of river
rows have talked to me about sort of how
it feels now I'm training and all this
sort of stuff and it's it's different
again from those guys because they're
generally racing on really flat sort of
glass like rivers or lakes yeah and they
don't have to deal with whether all that
much yeah whereas I'm constantly moving
there was fairly rare go in the water
super clean and come out super team so
you might put two wars in one you know
you catching crabs straight away or yeah
your guests pull back hands or pull down
onto your thighs
since I think trolls rough a lot of
people that we've seen rowing on what
before it'll be Oxford Cambridge Boat
Race stuff like that which is like yes
like as flies [ __ ] yeah yeah and guys
displaying like amazing balance and
they're both super rigid and they don't
move around at all yeah and I've seen a
video of one of your friends recently
other things out on the water at the
moment yeah I saw the video they eat
uploaded from the cabin looking at him
yeah and it just looks like hills it
just looks like a crazy golf course that
yet that he's wrong over the top of mine
yeah it's not so for instance I'd like
to describe the conditions he recently
woke up in his cabin with his eyes sort
of all blackened and cuts all over his
face right because why he was asleep he
capsized and it's like a washing machine
inside the cabin most of the time so and
it's you said it was sealed right so
yeah so he was just backing around with
this sort of coffin I woke up with his
eyen sort of bad order like but he's
he's the guy I mentioned before Damian
he was just sort of an example of health
tackle it so he just sort of laughed it
off took it for what it was and he's
just cracking oh he's just cracked on
yeah Wow
and then later that day I think he was
on the deck and it capsized two gaps I
was twice in a day man and he said he'd
just sorted it you know he was prepared
for that because he'd heard of it before
so he's he's like he's how I sort of
like to tackle it and like you look at
him and it really sets you up well for
for what's coming because he doesn't
like sugarcoat it and make up it's
easier than it is at the same time he's
just honest like he just says what a bit
it's also glorified yeah and he's not
saying are the hardest thing I've ever
done in my life and all this sort of
thing you're gonna if you go into it
thinking it's not going to be the
hardest thing you've ever done
you're an idiot so I think as long as
you are aware of how difficult it's
going to be it's not gonna be that many
nasty surprises but also I think the
amount of people that get into this sort
of thing they're not going to do it
lightly because they've already filled
it out an awful lot of people just
through the madness of saying you're
gonna do it I think yeah I think yeah
that that video scenario always
explained in full of is a good a good
like litmus test I think for the general
are no one in the room you know monitor
even
we're going crazy and I don't like I
know I'm not normal like them against
the grain of what makes people think is
you know normal or whatever like that
but I just like I said before I I find
value and other things that some people
don't and I think that sort of you know
as much as people want to progress in
business and see how much money they can
make and all that's for stuff that's
admirable and its own world but I'm not
made of that sort of stuff like I want
to see what I can put up with and why
can achieve in other worlds and it's
just so Howard bred I suppose many
people read differently yeah so going
back to the race so you've got yourself
out of Portugal hopefully you managed to
pull yourself away so that you can't
drift in of things yeah it's gonna be
finding your feet for the first week to
ten days yeah and then what happens ten
days in where are we there ten days in
is hopefully set a rhythm I know what in
the scenario what my shed you are on the
boat is gonna be more like so maybe roam
three hours and rest them for one hour
or row and to rest in teeth and you know
although all the jobs on board that you
do while you're not rowing say like
cooking and cleaning and maintenance
small that sort of stuff hopefully on
top of all of that by ten days in and
yeah and just sort of you know making
good chunks into the distance so the
guys on the tasks are eggs for example
they've been rowing for like two weeks
now and they're still only halfway
through right I know one that actually
has passed the halfway mark right so
it's just that it's known every day it's
breaking everything down into small
chunks so if you can cover 60 miles in a
day you're doing well as a solo so
that's you know you break that target 60
miles down to 30 miles fact we half-day
yeah and just keep on going through it
like that so yeah hopefully by day 10
nothing so they you know a good chunk
into the race a couple hundred miles
down and just sort of not really looking
at the miles to go because I'd be a
little bit disheartened and the three
thousand and odd miles and yeah and then
just enjoying the experience is the main
thing for me thank too many people come
back from the race and they've treated
the
thing is a you know a pressurized race
whether they're not really appreciating
where they are what they're doing
there's a book I've read recently by a
guy called John Fairfax who wrote solo
in 1969 right so he did it basically
like compared to me on the bones of his
ass like he doesn't have any kid none of
the electrodes for the stereo right yeah
yeah definitely
he had no food he caught most of his
food that he ate on the road
no so all that sort of stuff I've got
like fishing rods and a spear gun and as
much as possible I'll sort of try and
enjoy the experience
yeah rather than just treatment it so
sort of never got a volley wallaby yeah
let's come up a few times yeah there
Wilson yeah that would be quite cool so
one thing that I didn't understand was
how you secure yourself when you can't
touch the floor of the ocean for
sleeping so you don't drive okay yeah so
you've got a thing called a pair anchor
which is like a 12-foot parachute and
it's out on like a 100 meter lane right
so you've got a big thick rope
you attached to the boat and then you
put the power on cow so that the current
obviously that's going underneath the
boat the power anchor harnesses that
current then it keeps the nose of the
boat basically into there as well yeah
so that your position is held yes you
won't gain much distance while you're
under on a parent and ideally you're not
going to lose much either
and then also in bad weather you can
deploy the power echo and it'll keep
there from the boat pointing into the
bad weather yeah so that you're going
sort of up and down rather than
side-to-side for sure and it it's meant
to eliminate the possibility of capsize
but it doesn't but your friends proved
in yeah twice a 24 oh yeah so the
general rule of thumb is if you've got a
boat that same 3 metres wide if you get
hit side on by a wave more than 3 meters
you're gonna you going over yeah and
it's the Atlantic Ocean so most of the
waves are sort of a or 9 metres okay see
if you hit one sideline you goin over
Wow so I think it's important as well
for if anyone
thing's gonna do and it is to understand
it's how many times you're going to
capsize rather than a few of any capsize
I've been comfortable with the fact if
it's gonna happen
Wow so yeah so in terms of the route
that you're taking and you've spoken
about the the streams and the wind that
you gonna catch am i right in saying
what you said to me that there's gonna
be some times where you may be on the
crest of a wave going in the right
direction so to speak and you can kind
of almost surf that a little yeah
definitely Apple at the right pace too
right yeah so in what normal people
would consider bad weather in certain
situations for ocean row in it it's
really good for you because you'll get
picked up by a wave as you're rowing
yeah and then the common thread is the
ditch the oars just let go of them and
they'll sit in the gates and they're not
going to go anywhere and then you grab
your hand steering ropes yeah basically
steer yourself down the wave and you'll
pick up maybe like between sort of six
and ten knots right which isn't very
fast walking from A to B but surfing
down away from this sort of free money
source yeah yeah so you're flying along
and then anyone understands surf and
obviously waves come in sets so if
you're doing that every sort of 10 to 12
seconds you're making up some really
really good distance by so a lot of this
I guess a lot of the ease of the journey
is going to be dependent on mother
nature
yeah and also it depends on my for one
of a better term eyeballs
is my friend leavin and it's doing
whether we're going for the like five
teams are on the talus chorus right now
yeah I know is it leaving this house the
other night
and as we were speaking here to keep
them dashing away they're like funny
people on the race and give them their
weather office right and one of the
teams who spoke to you or on Parker
because the weather was bad yeah in
inverted commas so they were just gonna
sit there and write it out and then
expect to a four-man team a group of
boys from up here actually and they were
they wanted more women they wanted more
speed so they were like surfing down the
waves as we've just described there so
it's it's it's understanding what bad
weather is because there's a fine line
between free speed and putting yourself
in the dangerous position for sure um
but it's you know so it's nothing what I
do you think
ranked on the scale would you say that
yeah I'm pretty happy because I mean at
the risk of sounding too confident I've
worked on the Indian Ocean for sort of 2
or 3 years and you know witnessed some
pretty bad weather yeah
and that was when we were on sort of
cargo and cargo carriers and tankers and
oil rigs yeah and we were a little bit
worried so that was pretty bad over
there so if I experienced anything like
that then definitely not be like a case
of buttoning down the hatches and you
know surviving yeah but I think most
scenarios it's gonna be sort of
harnessing what you've got I'm just
going that elusive it yeah so I saw
something online that you posted about a
sheepskin seat cover yeah and then
someone asked why you had a sheepskin
seat covers yeah and what are you
wearing to Rowan so generally I think
eight percent the time people are
ballroom naked and leaving they
completely naked yeah
so the idea is that a few you could
probably test at home if you've got that
much time minimums but if you say
difficulty if your fuchsia gets covered
in salt water yeah and then it dries out
in the Sun the water evaporates but the
salt crystals stay in the material and
they're abrasive so obviously if the
t-shirts rubbing on your skin especially
with rowing you're gonna end up like
sores on your armpits really bad really
fast
yeah and because you're at sea the salt
gets into the wound and it makes it
harder to heal and then obviously
because you've debilitated malnourished
all that sort of stuff you body's slower
at fixing itself anyway too bad yeah
Aravind yeah and that's gonna happen
anyway you've got clothes on or anywhere
where there's friction where is the
sheepskin because it's soft and fluffy
units like more of a natural fiber it
it's better at not retaining the salt
crystals and sort of man-made fibers are
so the idea is that you clean it out as
often as you can with fresh water and
then it's sitting on that naked is
basically gonna provide less friction
and roaming in a pair of shorts so if
someone goes past you on a boat yeah
they're gonna see and thank you for 900
dead yellow but yeah my my rowing yeah
for the first part you
you'd wear shorts for that reason the
middle of the ocean there's not many
people saw someone on holiday a holiday
in a yacht just coming on the Kazak yeah
and but I'll be in a position where I'm
not tired okay that's what I was like
before so in terms of avoiding sunburn
and stuff like that like even just like
the volume of stone cream you're gonna
have to take yeah so I use like these
zinc stick things yeah so just stick but
I generally through like jobs I've done
in the past I've spent a lot of time in
the Sun exposed to it and sort of big
chunks yeah so I get used to it pretty
quick and like I said before when I was
in Tanzania for a few years it was you
know something to put up with all the
time there so you get used to that
pretty quick but definitely from the
first part I'll be covered up and you
know after a hundred days you'll miss
the sunshine you're gonna come back with
a wicked time so yeah I'll be quite
leathery so fresh water as well like
what is a very very heavy yeah object to
take with you how's that working have
you got something you can distill on
board yeah so on board I've got a
desalinator
or a water maker and basically it's
plumbed into the boat so there's a valve
underneath the hull like the bottom of
the boat and it sucks up seawater and
then through loads and loads of
different filters mega high pressure
turns it from salt water into drinkable
water doesn't taste particularly great
but you know it keeps you keeps you
going when you need it yeah and then
also because the type of boat I have it
needs ballast just so they set it down
in the water and again reduce the chance
of capsizing yeah so in the ballast
that's gonna come in the form of about
120 kilos of fresh water just in plastic
bowls that you get from the shop sort of
thing and then if the water maker breaks
my handheld will make a brakes as well
yeah I've got emergency what was the
last mute sort of you know sufficient
however long it could any idea where
that would be if you drink any of the
fresh water in the balls you can do for
a place it with sea water mark the box
so you don't drink it yeah and that way
you don't use any ballast your
to the print P emergency so that's
hydration what about food food comes in
the form of freeze-dried meals the
sponsor that I've got fire-pot company
called outdoor food that make that brand
they basically cook their meals and then
do you hydrate them right okay so
they're way healthier than some of the
other ones out there in the market so I
want obviously mention their names but
they're super sugary so you're actually
having fully cooked meals that just
about the water table yeah and then you
just pour boiling water back in but
vacuum pack for bikes
yeah leave it for like 15 minutes and
that's rehydrated and it's all like
chili con carne ultimate proper soup
yeah exactly yeah and they they're like
a thousand calories each meal stuff like
that so how much you're gonna be eating
every day so I put four of those every
day as well as a snack pack in the snack
packs got about 3,000 calories in it
that's a nine pack with three thousand
yes it's like lots of I've got loads of
nut butter some biltong because
apparently people say that you miss
chewing because all their freeze-dried
foods like quite sloppy inside there so
the biltong is just basically flesh
ripped off yeah and it's obviously like
mega snack for protein and then I've got
sort of energy gels there's fat based
other than sugary ones and then battling
Spurs and flapjacks and stuff like that
it's all work so you eat sort of the
moderately well less yeah I think I'm
gonna be hitting about 7,000 calories a
day and then the argument is you burn
about ten so there's three thousand
calorie deficit every day so that's
about pound a day of way yeah exactly
going to be losing so what if we say
it's around about 100 days in a hundred
days from January 18th yes your weight
gonna be I think what do you've got the
vast majority of people that do it say
they lose about a quarter of their body
weight so that's why I took the jump
from 85 to 112 I aimed at 115 I think
yeah but I think I'm about 112 of
minutes and there are there abouts yeah
and then
hopefully I'll lose over by the time
again if you came back in here at 120
have you realized yet super nice go got
a [ __ ] cut now and that we only got
my walk fight you cannot show my comment
about the time though yeah well you have
time so tell us about the rupture
recovery thangkas everything given here
is based around the charity right yeah
so to get a bit candid maybe a little
bit sort of controversial i generally
you know a lot of other people wanna
bring to the fore how much PTSD is
ignored I think people that come back
from Afghanistan
injuries physical injuries are pretty
well looked after now they don't get the
the best care that they could possibly
wish for but it's it's pretty good so if
you lose a leg for example you're going
to get process ik and it's going to be a
very good sort of standard but
unfortunately the same can't be said for
mental health if you come back with a
brain injury or with post-traumatic
stress or anything like that you're just
not well looked after at all
it isn't clear what haven't you you
should be going down to seek help it
isn't clear what kind of signs and
symptoms to look out for in people do
you like do you think that this is
across us UK yes like you like the
suicide rate for sort of veterans is
sky-high and a lot of it is because of
you know post trauma sort of incidents
that they've experienced or if they've
you know been in high-pressure
situations for huge chunks of the lives
which Afghan in the right provided you
basically leave the service and you
don't have any transitionary sort of
support you would just you know one day
you were flying around jumping out
helicopters and shooting people and
stuff and the next day you're in
Waitrose getting annoyed knowing the law
yeah getting in your way when you're
trying to apply tomorrow or whatever so
it's a really hard thing to come to
terms with especially with the fact that
there's no help out there and rocks or
recovery is a charity that's sort of
changing with
so they're providing help for veterans
and the families who have to deal with
PTSD sort of bringing over injuries and
stuff like that and it's like a fast
action charity as well so if anyone for
example if you had a friend or a
relative or whoever that was in the
forces that you were worried about you
could call up to recovery and they
literally fly up to see that friend or
relative and give them like immediate
one-to-one support like there and then
Good Samaritan let's put yeah really
arias son obviously it cost a fortune so
raising money for a charity like that
and trying to raise the awareness of
them as well is like really important we
know I think I've got a friend BT or
Ella who started that sports in America
which is a wounded and PTSD yeah
supporting sport elite so they play like
baseball and a whole bunch of other
stuff hmm he gave probably one of the
most moving talks I've ever heard about
a year and a half ago yeah and he went
through all of the different bits that
all of the problems that his friends
have had with PTSD he said that he was
one of the guys who'd come out
physically injured quite badly but given
the choice between being physically
injured and mentally injured he was glad
that he was able to he'd lost a leg that
was with his analogy that he - yeah and
I think it just sounds so alien the
concept of PTSD and obviously being in
that high-pressure situation the level
of adrenaline that they'll have
experienced the soldiers have
experienced in one day of combat will be
more than most people experience in the
air time and like not only that you can
get away from the trauma side of things
just looking at something as simple as
transitioning from one career to another
for most people it's quite stressful but
for people like in the backgrounds that
I've sort of encountered you go from
this sort of high level like you know
whether the level of octane the
adrenaline and all that other stuff that
you're experiencing on a day-to-day
basis it goes from like a hundred to
zero yeah and you're expected just to
deal with that and what you're used to
the people that like people around you
their behavior that you used to that
changes all of a sudden as well so you
can't rely on people to
you know treat Li the same way or
anything like that so you've got a
you've got to transition your heads and
like the way you act and everything
you've ever known completely change that
without any certainty yeah at least and
like if you're joining the military and
you're you know you're doing that role
reversed so you're going from a very
sedentary lifestyle and all that sort of
stuff and they're joining the military
they take always the years to train you
up to understand it that they can then
send you to war and then when you come
back from war and you want to go back
into like civvy Street you're just sent
there you don't get silly transverse
things that they died down but they
don't have any like you backups exact
week so like that has a massive effect
on how people act on their reactions to
things like how they process stuff in
the heads and there needs to be help for
that there's like at the moment there's
no prosthetics for the moment but if
people whose legs or lose arms or
something they can get those limbs
replace the R obviously nowhere near as
good as haven't you the original paper
whatever but this like I said there's no
prosthetic for the moment so the more
help that people can provide by using
these carriers like Rupp to recovery
you know ones like it it's it's super
important to get to a point where people
aren't running out of options and
they're arriving at the door suicide and
people are losing their families and
enfant sort of things so so that's the
goal is to raise as much money as
possible where you ought to yeah so
we've I've raised about five grand for
them so far
the bulk of the money that's going to
come from the row itself will be while
I'm away I've experienced in the
build-up to the event itself that you're
taking far more seriously when you sort
of you know you tell people you're gonna
do it and then that sort of dies off a
bit then you buy a boat and that like
think makes people think Jesus is
actually gonna go through with it so
yeah and all the trains and all that
sort of stuff yeah so I think as soon as
I set off that would be a big thing yeah
and then also one of the founders of the
the charity foxy and is on TV quite a
bit with there
ses program on channel 4 I know he's got
another program coming out about drug
cartels and stuff like that in Venezuela
only he's not gonna make it
one of them a you when you're over now
yeah well he gave me a load of heads-up
about what's Menace was like at the
movies is basically a failed state
pretty lawless yeah yeah
so getting there is gonna be interesting
yeah you might just go fight in the ball
turret right give me some give me some
more food not going back yeah he's he's
basically gonna help sort of spread the
message and all that sort of stuff and
yeah I think like I said well I'm
actually out on the road that's when
they're sort of the money he'll come
chuckling in them and the BBC you're
gonna do an interview on the 5th of
January and then one of the main
sponsors is making a documentary so I
think in terms of raising money there's
about sort of the next six months is
going to be the big they did a big big
push yet yeah so in terms of you've got
rock to recovery on there I know that
you've got my protein as well who else
have you got on that this song yeah so
the two main sponsors are true potential
yeah they're an investment firm based in
nubbins they're northeast based company
and then the other one is airfare and
they're basically a flight claim flight
delay compensation company both owned by
friends of mine and that brings a
northeast basis or companies as well so
you taking a good sort of local bit yeah
so that's like that's an important thing
for me I wanted to get some of people in
the local area involved in it there was
a story in The Chronicle and all that
sort of stuff and like I said before BBC
Look North are going to come do it a
future on it so have you found it
difficult because you've said that you a
little bit of verse to kind of put
yourself on a pedestal when searching
the accolade that's a little bit more
extrinsic and stuff yeah have you found
it uncomfortable to have to be the
Instagram story guy the constant update
guy because as we've said when you when
you publicize
these milestones and the build-up to it
and presumably throughout as well when
you do those you kind of battling
against two things there one of them is
it'll raise more money for the charity
and generally a variety about the race
is good but on the flip side of
you're maybe doing something that
naturally you wouldn't have a preclusion
to do yeah and it's really I did a blog
post about it recently because it's sort
of you know it's one of those things I
don't berate anybody that does it and
that builds their profile and that's
what stuff because generally they're
doing it for good reasons and I do
understand that the more people I tell
about the road the more exposure the
charity gets in the more money that we
raise and all that sort of stuff but
also at the same time I've chose to do
the road solo for a reason like I like
my own company I like my own space and I
like being able to do things without any
sort of fuss and stuff like that yeah
and I also strongly feel that in terms
of like raising money before the road
and telling people what's gonna happen
before the road to me it's sort of it's
not important until I've completed the
task it's one thing to say you're gonna
do it but actions are remembered long
after words are forgotten
so actually completing the challenge
we're coming back and having the story
for me is way better than going what I'm
telling everyone you're gonna do it yeah
there's obviously seven years worth of
me preparing for an Atlantic Rome has
seen me see like send me his worth of
other people preparing yeah and the
amount of people that put it off for a
year or don't actually follow through
with it
or set all these big promises and failed
yeah it's crazy
so I don't want to put myself in that
position where I'm telling everyone I'm
going to smash it and I'm gonna do this
and I'm gonna be this guy and I'm gonna
raise this much money and all that sort
of stuff before it's actually done I
think I'm in a better position to talk
about it and raise the profile once I'll
actually achieve the milestone yeah then
to talk about it before it happens yeah
it's just it's one of those things it's
a world we live in
it requires that sort of excitement and
beat up and big hoopla that social media
is now yeah and hope left and alright
job of it so far but I could always
obviously use like more shares and
follows and all that sort of stuff so
what wow that you're on the roll if
people want to keep up-to-date with what
you're doing yeah is there going to be
you got access to Twitter if you go
so how can people keep up there's a
thing called a yellow brick tracker that
people will be able to download the app
for that and follow me on like a google
map sort of french like a Google Earth
image and they'll be a little like arrow
which will be me making like a really
slow progress across the data and then
also I can facebook and tweet using that
device as well uh-huh I can send photos
and stuff and perhaps the odd video I
was gonna say cos the guy yeah who
tumbled over he had would like it look
like a GoPro sort of thing yeah it to
the front yeah so there is it capability
these days for that that sort of stuff
but it's just it's very sketchy with
satellite comms if anyone's ever had
experience with that stuff it's hard to
get the videos up and out well when you
can't get 3G in the middle of exactly
the area trying to get video in the
middle of your house but it should be
good I think it's one of those things
that you sort of you start sending on
Tuesday morning and it actually goes up
on Friday afternoons yeah I'd be like
that um but yeah I mean it'll be a blog
every day and all that sort of stuff and
then Lauren's gonna control the social
media stuff alright yeah thanks for
stuff like that ceramic so we're gonna
have to be careful especially feeling
naked of just what foot does end up
going up yeah yeah well so so I've
joined everything to a close
where can where can we find more
information about the role over the next
the next few weeks and then once once
everything's up and running working um
came up to down the story if everybody
goes and checks out rock through
recovery UK on Facebook and Instagram
it's just a prop to recovery UK and it's
a number two not ta so go look on that
or if you go to any of the platforms and
put in Atlantic soda juice into it
Facebook or Instagram and that be links
there towards the fundraising pages to
hand road to recovery and then basically
like I said I'll release like a page
that people can follow while I'm on the
road yeah like a week before I leave so
that I'll have the track of information
and everything on there and yeah it's
not really the best way to follow it the
fantastic
well thank you very much for coming on
I'll make sure that all of the links to
everything you've put in here tore up to
recovery to the links to follow yourself
will be in the description because look
man yeah all I can say exactly my
appreciate from me yeah
thank you very much Cheers
[Music]
you